to find out we've invited Kevin Parker
on the show tonight he's the New York
state senator from Brooklyn you just saw
on that tape senator Parker welcome
thanks for coming on tonight thanks for
having me on Tucker so I should just say
at the outset what I'm sure our viewers
already know which is already against
federal law to sell firearms to the
mentally ill thank heaven and I think
all of us support that restriction so
it's already against the law
but what other constitutional rights
that we as Americans possess should be
contingent on how we behave on social
media well let's be clear I take an oath
that supports the amendments and in the
whole Constitution both the US and the
state government Constitution and so
this is really not about impinging on
constitutional rights this is really
about safety this is really about how do
we in fact make the state of New York as
safe as possible
now we've already been very safe with
one of the top three safer states in the
entire country particularly you look at
you know you know mass shootings thank
God but we can always be safer and we
can always make sure that what happened
in Pittsburgh what we saw in Parkland
what we saw in the land Oh doesn't
happen here
and so this this law simply says let's
look at you know what people are putting
out on social media as a you know the
you know part of a set of criteria that
we're using to determine who gets
handguns because and by the way I agree
with your desire to make your state and
every state as safe as as we possibly
can
but why restrict it to gun owners I mean
you are an elected official you're a
state senator you wield a lot of power
you control people's lives why shouldn't
I have the password to your social media
accounts so we can assess whether you
should be wielding the power that you do
well somebody should put that Lauren and
maybe we can we could do that my first
of all did you send me would you send me
your password Tucker Tucker my social
media is open right now you can go on it
and look at it anybody can look at is
public information why don't you send me
your passwords and I'll find out how
open it well again you're again you're
requiring gun owners to give you their
passwords why shouldn't they turn around
and ask you for the same that's what's
your position look what we should be
talking about is how do we
make the state of New York safe and I'm
simply saying right now we're not as
safe as we can be because people are
saying things on social media and we're
not using that and looking at that as we
in fact give out a weapon that can that
is used to kill people okay but I get
what you're saying I guess I'm just
wondering why we're restricting I mean
as long as and you've said that privacy
is not a concern and if you have
concerns about privacy you know don't
don't carry a gun don't buy a gun okay
but you're saying that that's the only
category to which this applies why don't
we apply it to voting again before you
vote and choose who runs the state who
controls your life why shouldn't you
have your social media checked I'm not
sure coach because voting doesn't
necessarily lead to people killing each
other this is really about access to a
guns no this is about access to guns and
we know that there's a direct
correlation with the number of guns that
are available in in states and the the
prevalence of mass shootings that's
that's not true I think Wyoming has the
highest per capita gun ownership in the
country I don't think with the five
people who live in Y on me and the guns
that have the correlation between those
absolutely [ __ ] the absolutely is I
mean look at places like Japan and we
look at places like Australia they have
much lower gun violence just know but
you're not calling for limiting the
number of guns in this bill you're
calling for people to turn over their
social media passwords so you can decide
whether they've said things that are
naughty and if they have they don't get
to own a gun and so my question is what
other constitutional rights are
dependent on your approval is the right
to abortion should we before allowing
women to have abortions check their
social media accounts this is a Syrian
and if if not why not
Tucker I'm really focusing on the issue
of gun violence
there's too much gun violence in our
communities too much violence and
spreading across the country I
we get it but - hold on who's gonna make
this I mean you're obviously not a state
police police police but they'll just
decide typically before we determined
someone is mentally ill we adjudicate
that person mentally ill that this is
not about mental illness this is an
addition in addition to the other
criteria that the New York State Police
will use and they already use to
determine who should be eligible to get
a gun permit in addition to that what
I'm saying is we should also have the
state police review the social media
accounts of the people who make
passwords right and so on but what would
cause this to the state police
independent of a judge just get to
decide whether you can have a gun or not
based on whether or not they like what
you said on Facebook well the state the
state the state legislature has the
ability with with the signature of the
of the governor so in fact make law and
so we make it the law we then can in
fact that subscribe police no of course
they do it yeah the police gets
unilaterally decide whether we can
exercise our constitutional rights
you're comfortable giving the know that
the state legislators actually decide
that's that's in fact not done exactly
so in every case oh no what we do that
or they already have that power right
now right at this very moment the state
police decide who gets a gun a human
question do you think it's a little
intrusive that the government would be
forcing citizens to turn over their
social media passwords to the police
before doing something that Constitution
guarantees than the right shoe that
doesn't bother you in any way that
doesn't seem a little bit safe
totalitarian or some good maybe China
would would do Tucker we make
legislation through a process all the
things that you have objected to there
are lots of people who object to it
there's conversations that are going on
maybe all that you skirt the third
question I'm saying to you that there's
a process so there's a process
opportunity for us to work together so
in fact look at this maybe the parents
were you've written
these are your proposals so this is
absolutely but something that you came
up with it I'm just asking you as you
sat at your laptop and typed out you
will be required to hand over your
passwords to the State Police and if
they don't like what you say you don't
get to exercise your rights right now do
you think that sounds a little Orwellian
right right now right now right now
you're focusing on the part there's
actually quite not the whole bill right
so the big thing is to review social
than that mrs. Lincoln how was the play
I mean right it's part of it and you
don't see that as fascist in any we're
there any other decisions that I mean
should the State Police have to sign off
on your marriage do you think or how
many kids you can have would that be I
mean because obviously some people
shouldn't be getting married right we're
talking what we're again concerned about
is the safety of the people in the state
of New York and we're concerned that
that people get shot down well I know
what I'm doing what I'm doing is is
talking about the values and this and I
get that some people what you're do
believe that having a gun is more
important than protecting the lives of
strangers last question yes do you think
that people have a right to say
outrageous things maybe even things you
disagree with in public do you think
that your Zayas certainly can say
whatever they want to say but we also
have the rightness you also understand
we also have a right to deny them a gun
permit if in fact we believe that the
things that they're saying may lead to
them endangering the people of the state
of New York Supreme Court has already
said that that some speech say something
naughty for instance for instance we we
we limit you know speech all the time
like pornography particularly child
pornography right 67 which is the final
word on speech from the supreme court
since you're interested and it allows
all speech except speech that calls for
imminent violence Oh like getting a gun
and running it to a synagogue right now
I would call that imminent violence
right so really just violence
well again
really scare me so we have to live so we
have the limit violence and I'm saying
you limit violence by living its economy
we have the limits file and allowing
privacy no come on alright come on give
me your password all right I'm gonna
send you my text and you text me your
Facebook password I'm gonna with Seth
okay think of it we could talk about it
great thank you very much thank you for
everyone good to see you